a guy asked me a question the other day
and
he's making two 300 grand a year
and he says
hey can i ask you a question i how do
you relate to people that only make 15
bucks an hour i said what do you mean he
said how do you relate i'm making you
know 250 000
how do you relate to people that make 15
bucks an hour i said bro you were just
making 15 bucks an hour three years ago
what are you what are you talking about
yeah but you know when you're saying no
no relax
you've officially been disconnected from
the customers that are buying from you
you don't even know what's coming next
for you when you start thinking that
you're that much bigger than somebody
that's making
15 bucks an hour because you're making a
quarter million dollar your income right
it was an interesting country he was
asking you were more asking for himself
yeah he's like well you know when you're
winning again you know it's like you're
making the quarter million how do you
relate to people the mindset of a 15 an
hour person like you were there a few
years ago you don't bro so but this is
the point though
when you're disconnected from the life
and the only people you talk to
are people that are within your circle
and they're going to the same parties
the rich congressman senators and you're
in it for too long
you forget that you got into this with a
cause to want to make impact to want to
make a difference to correct an
injustice now you're just attending a
party on a daily basis you're so
disconnected from the day-to-day stuff
you don't even know what's going on in
the streets so they don't go in the
streets and say so tell me how does it
feel like paying gas prices the amount
that you're paying how are you how are
you feeling right there well it's tough
why
my grandmother lives two hours away from
here i can't even go visit i used to go
visit her once a month i can't do that
anymore i told my grandma i can't come
by why
two hours away i drive a pickup truck
it's 70 miles per gallon i just can't
pay the six bucks so i'm not gonna be
doing it that's real that's the real
part a flight that used to cost 350 i
used to take this flight all the time
it's 350. now the flight is
580. i can't pay 580 right the flight is
gas you can't pay that the food like by
the way some basic prices that people
feel okay so
fuel prices in the last 12 months year
over year up 107
airfare up 38
hotels and motels up 22
butter and margarine uh 20
okay then you have ground beef may to
make up 14 bacon up 15 eggs up 32
percent apple up six percent fish and
seafood up 12
you see these stats that's coming from
department of labor and who feels this
you know who feels this you think nancy
pelosi feels this the average person
feels the average person who's shopping
is going to fill this stuff what about
the woman the congresswoman from i think
michigan
the other day she said i don't care
about the gas prices they don't bother
me i drive an electric car
now she rep she has constituents and
she's
lame enough to say something like this
publicly he's a newspaper
i have an electric car cost of 57 000.
how many people can afford that because
they're already paying off the car that
they have so yeah we just go out and buy
an electric car i don't care about the
price of gas she had the nerve to say
that it shows you how far detached they
are
and these are the people that are making
decisions for us that's what i'm saying
patrick this is
it's gotten so far out of hand
and if this continues on this path
we're in a lot of trouble so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
you